[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
do
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
did you take
is
hahaha
ladies and gentlemen please rise and
remain standing for the presentation of
the colors by the through their
rebuilding
and the performance of our national
anthem by technical sergeant stephanie
george
they're coming to the right
breathe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
bright stars
[Music]
as we should be
[Music]
is
[Music]
then i am
of the free
[Music]
what
please be seated ladies and gentlemen
please welcome 100
refueling and installation commander raf
beldenval
colonel troy panama
[Applause]
thank you
well it's a quite an honor and i just
want to say starting off
uh six visitors commanders chiefs
airmen families
our guests this is absolutely a bloody
evening and you know what a way to
welcome what is
going to be surely a special night
before we get started i gotta first say
thank you
thank you lieutenant colonel jessica
snyder
chief master sergeant brandon smith
as well as every single member
associated with organizing this
amazing event you all are an amazing
team
for putting this together and it's going
to be a world-class
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
event
now it's pretty hard to say this i hope
you believe it it is
absolutely truly humbling to stand
before
all of you and represent you because you
are
the best the brightest our great nation
has to offer
and as the son of an immigrant of every
mayor to a thailand
i personally know what it means to live
in the land of the free
and opportunity so thank you mom and dad
please stay strong we're gonna see you
next month
now tonight tonight is a demonstration
of the strength of relationships as
every single
one of you has played a crucial part in
ensuring the next success
from the pathways to the air commandos
to the liberty wing team recon
variability command
[Music]
[Applause]
tonight is a celebration of you
and for you finally to our gracious
hosts
and community members here in the united
kingdom
thank you for making us feel all of us
like we truly have a home away from home
apart from a couple disagreements of the
centuries
we have stood by our sides since 1785
and our bonds they just grows stronger
together now
more than ever so cheers to all of you
tonight is truly a special night as we
welcome our commander chief
and first lady on their first official
visit
abroad
[Applause]
so right here why pick a tiny cluster of
bases across the pond
despite our small footprint in east
anglia
we have a far-reaching impact that
ensures our nation's
ability to fly fight and win with air
power
anytime and anywhere and
despite our diversity sets we are all
masters of our name masters of the air
cyber and sticks and we
provide a true competitive advantage
that our nation
absolutely can depend on but let me ask
you this
who is it that we depend upon the most
for himself
while serving in an undisclosed location
for others it's on the other side of the
swiss ship
waiting with abiel we're after gdy
waiting in the cello lot at heathrow for
far too many of us it is hiding in plain
sight
just on the other side of our laptop but
tonight
tonight we're blessed to have the
cornerstone of our success
right by our sides right here in this
transformed hangar
is our families because families matter
must
now on paper we may call them dependents
but if you ask me the success we
experience
day in and day out is because of their
sacrifices on the home run
and their rare ability to improvise
overcome and adapt it's an education and
sacrifice
that our first guest tonight has worked
to highlight to others throughout her
career in public service and as an
educator
she has voted as an example of what
resilience in the face of adversity
looks like
she like all of us have been forever
inspired
by our families and recognized their
unwavering commitment
to our service as well as success that
sacrifice
perseveres so
without further ado it is my honor and
privilege
to introduce a real advocate for our
nation for two years
and a long and as long as the newest
member
sorry i need you to visit yourself
ladies and gentlemen please stand
finished please surprise
[Music]
and now teammates family members
please join me in welcoming to the stage
the daughter of chief master sergeant
and senior master sergeant
glasscock with sydney glascock our first
lady dr
jill biden and the commander chief the
president of the united states
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
ah what a warm welcome
colonel pedron and thank
you and melissa for all that you've done
to lead and
serve in this space and congratulations
on your new
host at the u.s transportation command
you know it's wonderful to be here at
middle
hall and for all the little kids here
i know
who helped us find a way to celebrate
you through this movie
and joe and i are always excited to
visit with our troops and their families
you know you sit down
don't pay attention
as the daughter of the navy signal in
world war
ii and a mother a major who visited the
delaware army national guard
and served in your inner back and now as
your first lady
i'm so proud to be here with all of you
to begin
our first overseas trip
for those of you who have served more
than 20 years
to the youngest military kids that i see
in the crowd
you are our ambassadors to the world
and thank you for representing us with
dignity
and pride our military
families may not wear our uniform but
you are as crucial to our military
as rhaegar is
in the united states we have all
all-volunteer
force and it continues only because
generations of americans see the
honor dignity and patriotism
of military service when you serve
your family serve too
that's why supporting the physical
social and mental health of our military
families
is a national security imperative
and the leadership here at milton hall
understands this too
in preparation for his visit
colonel cantona wrote this about you and
i quote
you may be familiar with the term
military dependence
but i will tell you over the past 15
months it became abundantly clear
just who exactly was depending on who
our military families already versed
in sacrifice are the true
unsung heroes
[Applause]
and the quote is right you are heroes
and your commander-in-chief and i will
need that as well
and that's why supporting you is so
personal to us
and one of my top priorities
through our white house initiative to
support military families called joining
forces
we're going to work on military spouse
employment and entrepreneurship
make sure that you can get quality child
care
when you need it and provide the
education
that your children deserve
[Applause]
finally no one has more strength
and grit and resilience than our
military families
but you can't do this alone
we have to help you carry this weight by
improving access to mental health
resources
ensuring everyone can put food on the
table and supporting
caregiving families and survivors
joining forces will expect every
government agency to step up
and be a part of this effort
we are going to make sure that the
family of our service members and
veterans caregivers and survivors
have what they need to survive to try
our military is a community bound
together by love
[Music]
love for our country love for the men
and women who serve beside you your
husbands and wives your moms and dads
and love for the communities that you
build together
and it's our obligation to match that
devotion may god bless
all of you our troops
and their families
and now i'm excited to welcome
our next speaker someone who is so
familiar with what it means to be a part
of a military family
sinking glasstop
sydney i know growing up as the child
of two service members comes with
challenges
but it will also help you to become the
person you are
today with a broad and
beautiful perspective of the world who
is able to weather
change and uncertainty i hope that you
know
how special you are and we are
so grateful for your and your
family's services
thank you dr time for the introduction
all the support you've shown for our
military families and your amazing words
tonight
let's give her another
[Applause]
and as a military child for my whole 14
years
i can appreciate what the words military
family really mean
with both my parents actively serving in
the military my mom's command chief and
my dad currently deployed
i understand that a military family
involves more than just my family
unit but rather everyone in this room
even if those of us here tonight don't
share the same last name bloodline
we always step up one another at any
given time
that's what makes each of you so special
that's what defines us
as a military family and that's what
makes me incredibly proud to share this
community with our next guest
ladies and gentlemen let us welcome our
commander-in-chief
for the president of the united states
[Applause]
[Applause]
hello
because we know that uh the whole family
serves i also want to thank melissa
i know uh i know your next assignment
jewish transportation commander
so congratulations and thank you thank
you thank you
the city 14 years old
when i was 14.
when i was 14 years old i would have
been
a musician scared to death
to stand up on a microphone with large
crowded small crowd
when
[Music]
for being a partner
and uh
do not feel great office i've been out
28 times
[Applause]
you know i want to thank you all
[Music]
1939 three wellington bombers took off
from men and all
and uh
over the course of world war ii under
the stationary
bomber throughout nearly 28 thousand
tons of bombs in the mountains
flying more than eight thousand sources
this space means significant source
british air power
proud history proud nation
i also know there's also all thought of
american air force by
this room tonight world war ii was when
the u.s army air force
formed a 100 uh bombardment
by the way my uh yes you know
my uncle who was killed in world war ii
in the kitty
was uh army he was the army aircraft
he got shut down
territory who supported operations from
d-day
to the battle involved our opponents
and when they first arrived in ukraine
43 years of such taking also
they're in the monarchy in the past time
to stay
known as somebody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
might be a few members of the united
states
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
damn proud
[Music]
thank everything you do everything you
are
there's nothing that joe and i don't
enjoy more than spending time with our
troops and their families
wherever we go in the world i had a
great honor being
out of afghanistan and iraq over
you're the best in our country it's not
actually
real ones you sign up and run toward
danger
less than one percent of americans make
the choice that you make
that you hate but the rest of us third
ninety nine percent
i've long said that as a nation
we have many obligations but we only
have one truly
sacred nomination only one
has to properly prepare and equip the
wounded sin in harm's way
and to care for you and your family both
while you've employed
and when you come home and now
that i have an incredible honor serving
your commander chief
i believe that even more strongly
you know i want to give an extra special
thank you
to all the families and as you heard
from jill with five proud military
family you know
everyone in this room knows about
military families are essentially
essential to our strength it's the key
reason
jill will be launched reinforced to make
sure
we're doing everything we can to support
our military spouses and children and
the mothers and fathers
just like this you know he not only did
an amazing job keeping the golden 19
under control
on base we took care of each other
and the mental health throughout the
initiative like this house connection
[Applause]
you all know
my mother
folks thousands of hours spent
volunteering to make sure
everyone who got through this was so
important i know that these last 15
months
had a lot of depression but all the
roads were passed together as one team
team milton hall and you never
let up on your mission i am so proud to
be here with all of you to kick off my
first overseas
trip as president i've been in a
nightmare many many times i've
visited
this is my first overseas trip despite
the united states
i'm heading to g7 and then the nato
ministerial and then
to meet with mr cooper to let him know
what i wanted to know
that the united states is back and
democracies of the world are standing
together
to tackle the toughest challenges and
the issues that matter most to our
future
that we're committed to leading our
strength
defending our values
and delivering for our people america's
better position to advance our national
security
and our economic prosperity when we
bring together the like-minded nations
to stand with us
these nations have shed blood alongside
us
in defense of our shared values
our unrivaled network of alliances and
partnerships
those are the key to american advantage
in the world and have that
they've made the world safer for all of
us
no matter how we are going to meet the
challenges today
which are changing rapidly we're going
to immediately
position the strength our alliances
weren't
built by coercion or maintained by
threats
for the ground on democratic ideals for
shares of the future
and where every voice matters
democratic values that are well
strengthened for national defense
if our british fans will excuse me
equality and evacuation and events
america is unique in all the world
but we are not formed based on geography
for ethnicity
religion but an idea
an idea the only nation in the world
found
on an emotional idea we hold these
truths to be self-evident
that all men and women are created
endowed by their creator
with certain animal rights including
life
literally
withdraws friends and partners to our
side
and for hundreds of years american
patients have fought
and sometimes died defending their
friend
close look walked included by the
president saying
america leads not by an example of power
but by the power of our example
all of you are service members around
the world
you are the solid steel spine of america
around which alliances are built and
strengthened
year after year these partnerships
have hardened and have been learning the
fire of war
and generations of americans and service
members
who fought like the original
bloody hundreds and those rfa products
and the shared mission to with the truth
flying
fighting winning them together
these bonds of history and sheriff's
sacrifice
run deep and are strong based on bad
news
they endure connection and camaraderie
between our troops this community of
american citizens
stationed in the uk u.s spending forces
and families
you are the essential part of what makes
up this special relationship
between great britain and the united
states
over the next few days as i said
i've been participating in meetings with
many of our closest partners
to t70 in cornwall and on the bus
is essential because no single nation
acting alone
can meet all the challenges we face
today because the world is changing
growing another artist the world's
change changed
terrible beauty has been worn
in a different place in the world of 10
years ago better position of a different
place
we have to build the shared future we
see
future nations are free from coercion
accomplished by more powerful states
where
the globe comes sea
it requires coordinating violations
we must all commit to an ambitious
climate action
forgotten about the western impacts of
climate change
global warming and warming to no more
than 125
degrees celsius
[Music]
this is not a joke you know what the
junction calls
the greatest threat face america global
of war significant population
fights over land millions of people
leaving
places because of every city loves
seeing indonesia
because the fights of what is very
oriented
with the g7 we plan to launch the
mission centers
to support exhibits and development
around the world witnessing high quality
high standard physical digital health
infrastructure
we have to make sure the new
technologies and norms of conduct and
cyberspace are found
including addressing the growing threat
of ransomware attacks
the government of our democratic values
not by the autocrats
who are allowing it to happen these are
all critical mass experiences of 2021
we're going to be driving this agenda
together with our 27 departments
the us and the uk are both founding
members of the neighbors the strongest
military and critical alliance in the
history of the world
and that's not my purpose our troops hit
shoulder and shoulder around the world
including
the bravest afghanistan in the past 20
and now we need to modernize our
alliance investigating our critical
infrastructure
our cyber capabilities keep us secure
against
every threat we faced over the last
decade
and the new challenge you're about to
face as well
for the european union leaders i'll
discuss how the united states can work
with europe
to address a full range of missions
require the full strength
of our transatlantic partnership
including working harder
to shape the new roles of the 21st
century economies
and only after these meetings with our
closest democratic partners
to develop a common agenda and a mutual
purpose
on travis regime to sit down and manage
that timely before
president vladimir putin
our two nations share incredible
responsibilities among them
and experience through teaching
stability and upholding
uncontrolled agreements i take that
responsibility seriously
but i've been clear the united states
will respond
in a robust and meaningful way when the
russian government engages
in harmful activities
i'm going to communicate that there are
[Music]
consequences
in the united states of europe
going to be clear that the transatlantic
alliance
will remain quite a vital source of
strength
for the uk europe and the united states
and i make sure there's no doubt
and whether the united states will rise
in defense of our most deeply held
values
and our fundamental issues here's why
it's all matters so much right now
i believe we're in reflection
the moment where it falls to us
to prove that democracies might just
endure
but they will excel as we rise
to seek enormous opportunities in
democracy is over as some of our fellow
nations believe
we have to expose this fault to
narrative
the decrees of dictatorship
you know i know they're wrong
but it doesn't mean we don't have to
work harder than ever to improve the
democracy
when i see is i see america
i see american people in different
backgrounds coming together to share a
mission
our democracies haven't been perfect
but americans of all races religions
sexual orientation immigrants native
americans
all have stole their blood to defend the
battles
generation after generation american
earth assignment
department of fight because they
understand the truth
that lives in every american heart
that liberation opportunity
justice is far more likely to come
to pass the democracy than the emerging
autocracies of the world
i promise you that's what this is going
to be all about
for your generation another dear
children
here's what else is going on with that
there's not a single thing nothing
nothing beyond america's confidence to
accomplish
your honor your commitment to
and crash somewhere and put a man in the
moon
to help out their marks come on and
there's nothing nothing nothing
here
i want to thank you again for welcoming
me today it's great to be here in the uk
it's great to be here seeing you first
see all of you with the best possible
way to start this trip
let me inward again i say thank you
me and from the bottom of my heart in my
word
thank you all
thank you all for your understanding
that we're a nation based on values
thank you all for the protectives
may god bless you all
thank you
[Applause]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh uh
[Music]
good
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh okay
[Music]
yes
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
nice
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
put
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this
[Music]
yes
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
guys
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh
i
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
are you done
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
thank you